if you want to prepare for the s80 the
best way to prepare is to do your work
every day you don't you don't it isn't
it isn't what you do in the the senior
year before you take the s80 or the
junior before you take an essay t that
you prepare for that's 80 I mean the
reading part of it the more you read the
better you do on it the math part the
more you study mathematics and work at
mathematics the better you do on I don't
know how you can run and an admissions
process in the United States where the
schools have the the the choice of what
students they invite to come to their
schools unless you have some sort of
objective measurement I don't think it
should be the only measure but you need
some objective measurement because an a
in one school certainly it in what an a
is another school so if you just use
grades that that's not that's not a good
enough criteria now you have to look at
what the students done the
recommendations that they get from their
teachers and their schools but you need
one objective a test that allows you to
see the with other students what what
what is how well a student is done on
that test and there's a there's
obviously a correlation between how well
a student does on on an essay and how
well they're prepared to go to college
and succeed
well I think the one thing that that I
would say is I don't want somebody just
to rely on the s80 I wanted the more
information they can get about a student
the more they understand the student
body they want to have the better it is
I don't think this sa t is the beginning
and end of the admissions process I just
think it's an important objective tool
that statistically has proven to be very
helpful in that admissions process and
very much part of fairness